you might be wondering why may musk
mother to one of the world's richest
people elon musk is posing with
pomegranates and wearing a custom
embroidered cashmere sweater that says i
love my mitochondria
the author model and registered
dietitian with two master's degrees has
taken on the role of spokesperson for
timeline nutrition
the company is owned by amazentis a
swiss life sciences company currently
seeking 43 million dollars in funding
for its ongoing series d fundraising
round big name pharma investors include
andre hoffman of roche holdings pierre
landolt of novartis and billionaire
hangzhou whis
the company is helmed by chief executive
and co-founder chris wrench along with
dr honorag singh who serves as the
company's chief medical officer in
oversees midopura's clinical studies
the pomegranate musk is posing with
contains the secret ingredient to
mitopure urolithin a a compound which is
naturally created by some people's gut
bacteria after eating foods containing
what are known as a lag attendants like
pomegranates
timeline claims that urolithin a
compound stimulate mitophagy a fancy
scientific term for renewing
mitochondria the performance of which
scientific research says will slow as a
person ages
amazentis says they have more than a
decade of research that claims to show a
connection between the supplement
revitalized mitochondria and a boost in
muscle function
first we tested eurolitan in the worm
and we showed it extended lifespan by 50
percent then we tested the rodents where
we showed that it improved endurance by
about 40
or work showed for the first time the
importance of mitophagy in the aging
process
[Music]
while the company has proven to the food
and drug administration that its
products are safe to ingest more
research is needed to support its other
claims as supplement manufacturers don't
have to prove their products work mae's
been taking the supplements for five
months but states she hasn't noticed a
difference yet explaining that it's
happening in the cells
the exact amount she's getting paid to
promote timeline was not disclosed
when reached for comment on whether musk
receives money from her son and if she's
a spokesperson to make additional income
timeline's public relations
representative told forbes quote this
has nothing to do with elon musk may has
her own life and her own career i don't
find this question very appropriate
may's mother lived to be 98 years old
and may says if this is going to
continue to repair my mitochondria i'm
hoping that this will be the new
anti-aging supplement to take
[Music]